dubai for me is a chance to be a part of
building the foundation for the
underground music scene
i think all feeling can be felt in music
i've been diagnosed with a critical
hearing loss so i have really two
choices
stop making music and the other option
is
making music while my ear supports me i
choose the letter
[Music]
my name is erin kim
aka tessette i do sound design and make
electronic music i'm from south korea
and i've been living in dubai for nine
years now
i'm in fact a cellist
and uh
i changed my whole music making process
with electronic music because in
electronic music there is no wrong and
right you don't need to follow any
structures you are 100
free
classical music is very very strict
what i love about electronic music is
you don't have
any rules any theories nothing to follow
when i need or want i go out and record
sound from the ocean
from the desert
come back home to my electronic
equipment and i start to make music with
the sounds i recorded earlier i'm trying
to incorporate my my cello sound in a
very unconventional sense it's like
heavily synthetized heavily granulized
chopped up
i think the very basic foundations and
backbone of any city is art and music
there's a lot of people setting up new
things here there's a record store
called flipside run by my friend shadi
he was the first guy to open a record
store in dubai
underground music scene is really
growing in dubai and it's new living and
creating in dubai means i'm part of
growing and building that scene
so many people here are like me they've
set up home here and are bringing a
little bit of what's theirs into the
city which in turn i think is creating a
really strong creative undercurrent in
dubai
you